here's what would happen if it rained
volcanic glass
well first you would see a beautiful
light show from the Sun reflecting off
the clouds onto the volcanic glass also
known as pele's hair driving in a
rainstorm would be even harder you'd
need to avoid using your windshield
wipers or the volcanic glass would
scratch your front windshield your
health could also suffer from volcanic
glass rain if pele's hair got into your
skin you'd end up with itchy red rashes
breathing it in could cause respiratory
problems pele's hair might even end up
in your drinking water the strands are
so fine they could bypass water
filtration systems on the upside with
all this material falling outside for
free you could recycle it using it for
projects like building insulation if you
live in a place with frequent rainfall
like India Denmark or Singapore you
should consider packing up your things
because